good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight so as you can tell even by the
standards of a
late october thursday in a presidential
year there's an awful lot going on
donald trump and joe biden meet for
their final debate tomorrow in nashville
for example
in a normal year that would be
considered a very big deal presidential
debates give voters critical information
about the candidates in the days before
an election
they used to be considered a good thing
an essential part of our civic life but
it's not anymore
this year the debate commission has
decided to cut the participants
microphones if they talk too much
so you won't be able to hear the people
you're supposed to be voting for in a
week and a half
when they speak that's an odd decision
but in a way it makes perfect sense
given the moment
if there's a unifying theme on the left
right now it's that more
information is bad it's scary voters
shouldn't know too much they have no
right to know
so stop with your imperious questions
about what's happening around you
questions about george soros or
mandatory flu vaccines or blm's
long-term agenda for your children stop
and above all please shut up about
hunter biden's
laptop stop not another word about that
this is not a suggestion by the way it
is an order and it's been delivered by
the most powerful people in the world
silicon valley billionaires the news
media the federal spy
agencies even borat himself
all of these people every one of them
wiser and much richer than you
are would like you to know that there is
no reason to ask
a single question about the documents on
hunter biden's computer and there are
countless reasons not to ask
for starters it's all russian
disinformation it was planted by
vladimir putin himself to discredit
washington
lobbyists who honestly have done nothing
wrong
the documents are also quote hacked
material
that means that not only are they fake
but someone stole them
you want to be party to theft didn't
think so and while we're at it you
should also know that rudy giuliani
could very well be a sex offender and
that means that hunter biden's emails
cannot be real you starting to get the
picture here
no more questions america curiosity
killed the cat if you know what we're
saying
if you care to keep your social media
privileges to live in this country
you won't say a word about the laptop
just ask the new york post what happens
when you get uppity and start thinking
the first amendment is real
so that's where we are right now october
21st 2020 and it's all pretty
amazing it's instructive too what we've
really learned is that the class system
in this country is real more real than
we ever knew
if you're a member of the group that's
in charge right now you can do pretty
much whatever you want jeffrey epstein
understood that early on
when you're on the right team you can
publish someone else's tax returns or
private phone calls and no questions
will be asked
is that legal who cares laws don't apply
to you
you could literally broadcast your
sexual fetish live on a zoom call and
keep your job at cnn
you went to harvard you're too important
to fire relax
it's not like you're a pro or think that
all lives matter
so those are the new rules if you're on
the wrong team and many are
it can be frustrating to watch all of
this because you know deep down that if
you dared to behave like these people
behaved
you'd be in very deep trouble you can
feel hopeless after a while
but then out of the blue something will
happen to remind you that actually there
is hope why because people this
awful cannot rule this country forever
they're not capable of it they are too
arrogant
they're too stupid how stupid are they
stupid enough to let their hypocrisy
show
in the end that will be their undoing
you cannot
impose rules you refuse to follow people
will not put up with that over time it's
too infuriating
and yet these people can't help
themselves tonight we've got an amazing
example of this it's a story worth
putting in the museum of hypocrisy
right next to bernie sanders private jet
and the automatic weapons mike
bloomberg's bodyguards carry
this is a good one the protagonist of
the story as is so often the case
is one christopher charles cuomo prime
time anchor on cnn
brother of a sitting governor before we
tell you the story however some context
the one thing you are likely to know
about chris cuomo other than the obvious
which is that he is fabulous lats
is that chris cuomo really believes in
masks
really believes with sincere religious
intensity
if there was a shrine to the patron
saint of paper surgical masks somewhere
in the countryside of portugal
chris cuomo would go there each summer
he would crawl on his knees
if he had to such as his devotion here's
chris cuomo
sharing his faith how do we help put on
the damn mask
if you're in california if you're in
riverside wear the mask
if you want to avoid situations like
this where you live wear the mask
if we care about doing the right things
i wear a mask for you as much as i wear
it for me
i had the disease you need to wear a
damn mask right
and you have to take care of other
people in your community and it's got to
be about us
because the help's not going to come
from above i wear a mask for you
as much as i wear it for me
chew on that for a minute it's a
powerful statement if you think about it
shades the beatitudes maybe the
letter from birmingham jail it's deep
this man
is suffering for us and for our sake and
all on a cable news salary
there's something holy about that but
the question is is it real
is this man actually dietrich bonhoeffer
or is he jimmy swaggart
it's pretty clear what his building
superintendent thinks this show has
obtained a letter from the management of
chris cuomo's new york city apartment
building
the letter in question is addressed
directly to chris cuomo
the date on it is august 6 2020. here's
what it says
quote dear mr cuomo as i'm sure you know
because of the ongoing covid19 health
crisis
on april 15 2020 governor cuomo issued
executive order
202.17 which requires anyone over the
age of two to wear a face mask or cloth
that covers their
mouth and nose while in a public space
okay that's how it starts
it's a fair guess that chris cuomo
already knew that because
after all he's the mask guy and of
course his own brother
issued the order so with that in mind
listen to how the letter continues quote
you have been observed entering and
exiting the building and riding the
elevator without the required face
coverings
even though staff members have asked you
to comply with this requirement
you have refused to do so this is a
violation of the executive order
building policy and it places other
residents
and our staff at risk there are no
exceptions to this rule and you are
required to comply
the letter goes on to threaten chris
cuomo with a 500
fine if he continues to endanger his
neighbors and the city with his
masklessness
that's what the letter says let that
sink in for a moment
now at this point we can guess what
you're thinking this has got to be
russian disinformation vladimir putin
hates masks obviously he's vladimir
putin he's bad
bad people don't like masks it's that
simple and putin would like
nothing more in the world than to
discredit chris cuomo because chris
cuomo
is this country's foremost and most
fearless defender
of maskedness so of course that's what
we assumed was going
on obviously we read the news but then
we did some reporting
in short order and honestly it pains us
to tell you this but we have to
this show has confirmed the letter is in
fact real it's not a russian plant
we called the building manager and she
spoke perfect english not a hint of
slavic inflection
clearly not a russian agent in fact she
admitted
writing the letter we should tell you
that she became upset when we mentioned
chris cuomo by name but we don't blame
her for that
you don't want to tangle with the man
who does squat thrusts while eating
lunch you don't know
what might happen but you do wonder
about chris cuomo
and you worry will his brother have him
arrested
back in may we learned that very well
could happen in new york
no one is above coronal law
i think it's disrespectful of people not
to wear masks
i mean think about it do i think local
government should be enforcing it
and should there be sanctions yes yes
because it is a public health emergency
then i think there should be a penalty
because you could literally kill someone
you could literally
kill someone because you didn't want to
wear a mask
you could literally kill someone
that's coming from andrew cuomo keep in
mind who knows more than a little about
literally killing people in new york you
could say
it's a specialty but we don't expect
andrew cuomo to
ship his brother to rikers the governor
didn't do anything
earlier this month when we showed you
that photograph of chris cuomo without a
mask
outside at a crowded restaurant on long
island and governor cuomo didn't do
anything either when his brother faked
being in quarantine earlier this year
and instead spent the afternoon hassling
bicyclists
chris cuomo is a good person so the idea
is he deserves a
fourth chance watch him make his own
case
all right so while most americans are
staying inside or should be
right if they're not out protesting like
fools they're not happy about being told
to stay home
staying home saves lives and the rest of
us should be staying at home
for our mothers and the people that we
love and to keep us
farther apart will ultimately bring us
closer together in this cause
no matter where the virus goes
the way to stop it will always be
the same our collective conscientious
actions staying home
you know you got to feel for the guy
we're mocking him but let's take this to
a deeper more human level
imagine being him by day there he is
giving you more sermons about how you
must wear
masks but by night he's wandering
masculists through his own building
endangering his neighbors
and ignoring demands that he put on a
mask chris cuomo must be deeply upset
with chris cuomo which of course we
already guessed from his exercise
regimen
it's not an exaggeration to say that
chris cuomo is a man at war with himself
how will this end